uh hello my name is uh kit furman i am
a genomics product manager for um the
cancer transcriptomatos
it's a it's a pleasure to be here today
um to talk to you about
um dsp the digital spatial profiler
and the cancer transcriptome atlas
so um so this is a great technology
from um nanostring of course you know as
a company we've been around for
quite some time and many people know us
for a gene expression
uh platform the encounter analysis
system but um in 2019 we actually
launched
launched a new system um called the dsp
digital spatial profiler
that does something really unique um
and delivers um great spatial
information along with
um both protein and gene expression
information so
um and that's really what i'm going to
focus on today
so i'm sure many users here perform
some type of bulk gene expression um you
know it's it's a great technology
whether it's on the end counter or
you're using
rna sequencing um and it tells us a lot
about
the biology um here is an example of a
signature that was actually developed by
merck it's called the tumor information
signature it was developed on encounter
um
but this concept is definitely
extendable to other
disease pathologies and it basically
tells the user whether or not the
tumor itself is inflamed whether or not
there's an active immune system
um but there's a lot of caveats to these
signatures because
you know it does predict uh response
to therapy in this case but there's many
patients where there might be a high
score but
no response and so we know that it's not
a perfect measure
of whether or not somebody will respond
to a particular therapeutic because
there's such a diversity
in the biology
so to illustrate that with
images i have two colorectal carcinomas
here
and these tissues have
almost the same inflammation score we
can see there on the top right of each
section so two different patients you
know one
has you know the immune system on the
left
inside in magenta you can see that it
hasn't really infiltrated the tumor
which is in green which is pancetta
keratin
um but on the right you can see this
really highly infiltrated tumor where
the immune cells the cd3t cells and the
cd45
cells are infiltrating into the green
portion
um and so these two patients even though
they have the same level of inflammation
you know are gonna their same level and
same scores
are going to have two very different
responses and so
you know what's lost in these bulk gene
expression assays
is some of this spatial information and
that's why it's so important
to help us understand the biology
of cancer but you know and generally
biology across the board in all
different domains
so that's really where the digital
spatial profiler comes in
it helps you take this high plex gene
expression information or protein
expression information and merges it
with um
the uh spatial data that you get from
a tissue section right so um you both
get the
precision and quantification that you
would expect um from
these county assays but also um kind of
the contextual information of where this
signal is actually coming from
so on the dsb system it
basically takes a standard tissue
section slide
and so you know there's a numerous
different
sample types that you can use on our
particular platform uh
both ffpe which we've optimized all our
assays for so forming fixed
paraffin-embedded samples
or you know fresh frozen samples a lot
of people will use
tumor microarrays on the platform
so it's pretty flexible in the input as
long as you can put it on a slide
you can run it on our platform
so this is a nice general overview of
um the dsp process on the left-hand side
you have
our reagents and so this is a lot of
where the power is in the platform
we either use antibodies or protein
detection
or ish probes for rna detection
and so you have on each probe
is a attached a dna olga or dsp barcode
um through a uv photo cleavable linker
right so this allows us to you know
stain these tissues and mass
with the probes and then what the dsp
system does it allows you to visualize
your
tissue then select a region of interest
and then it shines a uv light in a
specific
region that you've selected and it
illuminates only that region while
leaving everything else untouched
and it leaves your tissue intact very
importantly it doesn't destroy your
tissue
the because the dsp dna oligos the dsp
barcodes are attached
via uv photo capable linker when the uv
light hits those specific regions
the dna oligos come off the tissue and
then we
collect them distribute them in a
well of a 96 well plate so then that
allows those
dsp barcodes or the dna oligos be
counted
um on the back end so what that gives
you
is a very um distinct profile
quantitative profile of what's expressed
in each region of interest so you can
see on the right you have
each circle there it's a this is a lymph
node biopsy
and you can see each circle you'll have
a unique
profile for every single one of these so
instead of having a gene expression
signature across the whole tissue you
can now get a gene expression
or protein expression profile for every
single
region that you've selected and so now
you can place those regions
in spatial context
so um just real briefly we have a number
of different reagents so we have
protein assays for
immune oncology uh immunology um
as well as neuroscience panels so this
is really our protein offerings we've
we have pre-validated content for
foreign fixed para embedded samples
um right now everything's enabled to be
read out on the encounter
uh platform meaning those dna oligos
that come off the tissue
are read out on the end counter and
we're building out the capability to
have those read out
on um the ngs platform
now um the readout of these
ngs uh these uh dsp
uh barcodes or dna goes um the readout
on
um for our smallplex panels uh for rna
are in the encounter and then we've
expanded
the readout using the ngs system so
illumina's
ngs readout so that we can actually read
out a large number of genes all at once
so for the cancer transcriptome atlas
we have the ability to get over 1800
genes
at one time from every single region of
interest
so this is obviously a large amount of
information
from every single region so instead of
looking at the cancer transcriptome
across the whole tissue
you can look at it at various regions
throughout your tissue
and so these have the 1800 genes here
are specific to
immune oncology um and then
just to introduce you into what we're
doing we're
launching next year early next year is
the whole transcriptome atlas and so
this will be for human and for mouse the
other two panels were for
uh human but this will be uh
able you'll be able to measure um
basically the whole transcriptome
in every single region of interest so a
truly unbiased assay
so all the protein coding genes
so to focus a little more on the atlas
that we use today
this has over 1800 genes it covers
a wide array of pathways so everything
from
you know b-cell and t-cell biology to
stroma architecture and immune
microenvironment
i'm also quite a bit of tumor biology
and so this targets you know things like
cytokines and chemokines and
um growth factors and so forth um
there's a lot of annotations in this
particular panel we've uh
borrowed a lot from our encounter panels
so it has a lot of the
immunology signatures that you would
expect like pam 50
or the tumor inflammation signature or a
set of jeans
and of course there's the ability to add
custom targets
so this is the the panel that i'll show
you some data
uh with today um and this is
actually read out on um an illumina
sequencer so
once you have collected the barcodes the
dna goes from the tissue
using the digital spatial profiler
you'll simply read that out
on the illumina sequencer and then
import that data back into our system
so just to review um you'll take your
your section and you'll sustain it with
both imaging reagents which is an
important part of the
roi selection strategy you know um these
are um
rustling labeled antibodies or they can
be ish probes um
rna scope is compatible with our
platform
and so you'll stain it with these
imaging reagents and then
you'll also use our profiling reagents
so those are either the protein panels
or the rna probes the cta in this case
the cancer transcription atlas
you'll prepare the sample and then
you'll place it on the digital spatial
profiler
um and on the instrument you'll actually
select your regions of interest and i'll
kind of dig into what that actually
means and the flexibility of that
process
but then the system will allow you to um
cleave the oligos from every specific
region it collects those logos and
dispenses them in a play in a well and a
96 well plate
and then you count them on either the
end counter or the illuminati sequencer
so this just shows you the
reproducibility of the platform
you know these are on the right hand
side you can see two serial
sections um lymph node sections
and then you can see the reproducibility
of the correlation between
uh selecting the same region across two
different serial sections so
uh 0.983 uh
r squared value um you know this a
really this high level of
reproducibility
um allows you to uh you know
basically um measure
biological change um you know very
precisely
and you can see another thing to point
out here is that there's a large dynamic
range
as you would expect from this many uh
targets
so you see things that are highly
expressed but you also are able to
discern low expressors as well
so up to this point we've um i've shown
you these spatial images with
circles basically regions of interest
where we've created a polygon or a
circle
selected it and then illuminated that
particular circle
but on the instrument um is a
digital micro mirror device that allows
us to finally shape the uv light source
like a mask and so here in the middle
having a this is a
just a core from the tma um
and you could just create a circle and
take the whole core
as one profile but using this dmd
device we can actually cut apart
the tumor and the tumor micro
environment from one from another so it
actually allows us to finally dissect
out the two different
signatures and so in this particular
example
we'll get a profile for the tumor which
is on top
and then we'll get another profile for
the tumor micro environment so we
actually have two distinct
either protein or gene expression
profiles for what we're trying to study
and this really allows you to see the
interaction
between those two different segments
um so we've been running projects for
quite some time and so
over the years we've developed different
profiling
strategies so obviously the simplest
approach would be
geometric and many people like to do
this because it allows them to just play
circles or squares or polygons
over regions that have some
morphologically distinct
aspect to them so you know putting them
in regions with heavy amount of
infiltrate
or positive for a particular signal or a
particular morphological feature
um such as a part of the the anatomy
so they can simply mean move these
uh circles on top of it or you know
shape a polygons and kind of
fit whatever they're trying to study
you can take this a step further and
segment so basically segmentation allows
you to
um basically segment on the fluorescence
that you're looking at and say i want
everything that's positive for panasonic
keratin
or i want everything that is negative
for a particular
fluorescent marker and so it allows you
kind of like we said
cut apart different uh segments from
maybe the tumor from
the immune cells that don't treat it yet
and then just an extension of that would
be looking at you know
cell type specific population so
basically selecting all the t
cells or all the b cells in our
particular region
um and then there's also contouring
which allows you
to look at biological gradients in a
particular tissue
um so
so going back to our example here we
have two very different
tumors that have the same bulk signature
but
we want to profile them so that we could
really pick apart what's happening here
in a spatial manner so
you could just draw geometric circles
over each one of those
and we can see here at the top we have
um you know non-infiltrated tumor
regions right and so you can see that in
green and then at the bottom
we have these infiltrated tumor regions
uh
and it's not annotated here but the pink
on the left
are really uh the immune environment and
so the
infiltrated tumor regions look a lot
like
um the immune
positive regions right the magenta which
is cd45
um and so we can really tell that
there's something unique about the tumor
um in both regions one in the top
tumor somehow the tumor is excluding the
immune system
whereas the immune system in the bottom
one is able to get past that barrier and
infiltrate
so um we really you know we have this
this tumor
immune boundary here we really want to
uh better characterize it so
how do we characterize this uh this
invasive margin and so one way to do
that would be to select these
three different regions of interest and
then we can actually
contour across the region so you know we
draw the boundary
and then we're able to segment each one
of these regions across boundaries so um
we've taken three regions of interest
and we've basically split it up
into different contours so every
conjurer here is going to have
its own profile and so that
allows us to ask a lot of questions
about the tumor immune boundary in this
particular patient
and so we can see that you know the gene
expression profile
change from when we go inside the tumor
the outside you can see net gene
um heavily expressed within the tumor we
can see
um the hla dra gene expressed
in the tumor and then across the
boundary
um you know of course chemokines are not
highly expressed within the tumor
but then mhc class ii molecules are
highly expressed
along the border but then decrease the
farther away
that you get so you really get to see in
this particular roi
of the changes across the boundary and
how the biology is
how the tumor is interacting with the
immune environment
um and then the great thing about the
dhp platform is built for large cohorts
of samples so here we have
um two different patients one is um
the highly infiltrated tumor and the
other one is the immune excluded tumor
but this system is really designed to
have large cohorts whether they're tmas
or you're running
24 or 48 slides through the system you
can take all that data and put it
together
so here we're looking at you know the
differences in the immune response of
cd8s and cd3
t cells across the immune boundary um
and each dot here is a different um
measure at a different point along the
boundary um
we can see things like um you know in
this case
um the inflammatory macrophages
are enriched in the
inflamed tumor with the heavily
infiltrated
uh t cells uh we can see that distinct
difference here
and you know this kind of shows us that
there's a
strong m1 and m2 macrophage polarization
um with that particular patient
that has heavily infiltrated um
[Music]
immune cells into the tumor
and we can also take this data and we
could you know apply pathway
analysis to it so you can take things
like you know an
interfering signaling pathway and you
can basically
measure it across the border and what
we're seeing here is you know we've
taken many uh tumor stroma
boundaries across the whole tissue and
you know each line here
may it could be a different boundary
so there are other things that we can
ask with these particular samples
we you know maybe we want to know how
the t cell functions
are different depending on if it's a
infiltrated tumor versus one that has a
strong boundary
and so we can do that um here we've
selected regions that are inside the
tumor
and we've selected regions that are
outside the tumor so we want to know how
the t cells are changing if they're able
to get inside the tumor
you know how are they able to overcome
this barrier
and why are you know some t cells kind
of hanging outside
the tumor boundary and so what we're
able
to do is basically
select all the t cells and then we can
select everything that
neighbors a t cell right so you get both
this profile for what is happening in
the t cells
and then you can see how it's actually
affecting the environment around it
and so we can see things obviously um
you know just as a
um control your cd3 is highly expressed
in
t cells obviously and low league spread
see in the neighbor
compartment but then you have um you
know things like
um tim3 which is upregulated in t
cells within the tumor but not so much
in the stromal environment when the
t-cells in the stromal environment
same with 41 bb so you kind of pick
apart the different
uh t-cell profiles for those that are
inside the tumor versus outside of the
tumor
and and this is just some follow-up
experiments that we did with
interferon gamma on an rna scope to show
you know that inflamed phenotype
and so the last thing i want to show you
is um
just an example that
[Music]
that a customer did for a conference
earlier this year and so one thing that
we found is a lot of people have
either bulk or single cell rna-seq
information
that they want to integrate spatially
and so
single-star and i think has been great
because it tells you a lot about these
populations of cells but it doesn't
really tell you
where these cells are and so
we've developed methodologies to help
our customers uh do just that
um
so this is um alex warwick from the
garvin institute and
he's been working with triple negative
breast cancer
and so he performed um an analysis
with actually our whole transcriptome
atlas assay um where he was looking at
different
cell types in the tls structures
within the triple negative breast
cancers and so
just to give you the high level overview
he took
his single cell rna-seq signatures
because you can identify these very
clear populations of cells
um he then um created rois here in the
middle
um and then segmented on pancetta
keratin and then
um the stromal environment so really
everything else that it wasn't
tumor and then using these signatures
he was able to deconvolute the data
and understand the composition of each
of these segments and so
you could actually tell which cells were
in each of these segments
in these two regions and then across his
tissues in general
so it's a really good way to kind of
integrate both your single cell data
whether it's in cancer or neuro or any
other
tissue and take your single cell data
and then
use it in your
genomex dsp experiment so
with that i want to thank everybody for
your attention and interest
um you know feel free to reach out with
any questions
um and um you know you can find this
single cell decon on bio archives the
algorithm that we've just published
um or you know more information
about genomics and the cancer
transcription atlas
by emailing genomics management.com
thank you